herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich werde heute kurz und bündig
probieren mich so zu schminken wie babys
beauty palace das mal in einem video
getan hat war relativ schwierig für
normales schminkt wieder finden wir
irgendwie ist immer also hälfte
professionelles make-up hälfte
drogeriemarkt und ich meine kann das
überhaupt nicht sicher welche aber
probieren das nachzumachen wirklich mit
dem ziel ist sehr vernünftig
hinzubekommen
ja das ist relativ insofern weil
irgendwie für mich das volk so heftig
wie mädels sich schminken können und wie
genau und so was man diese ganzen
believe striche und sonst machen müssen
deshalb mache ich das heute also dann
fangen wir mal an ich bin gespannt wird
so leute also ich hab keine ahnung wie
man so ein richtiges fett ab macht um
sich zu schminken deshalb werde ich das
einfach so machen dann könnt ihr mich da
im spiegel sehen und ich stehe davor und
schwingt mich macht es ist einfach nicht
ich will sagen wir legen direkt dürften
echt gespannt ob ich das hinkriege
diese in diesem fall mein make-up und
ihn also mein alltag make-up dagegen
praktisch ein youtube-video fragen die
heute ganz ganz ganz anders wie du
irgendwie bewegt wollen habe ich voll
verändert aber auch nicht verschwinden
ihr make up hat sie in jedem video also
mach und dann werde ich bin gespannt
das abschminken supercup beschwingt auf
und ab geht erst mal auf meinem handwerk
möglichst mit dem film selber aufnehmen
kann
ok ich brauche ich zufälligerweise
beweglichen sachen nein stimme meiner
freundin die mir das freundlicherweise
führten schnell und ich habe hier das
neumarkt und ich bin ja bekannterweise
euren nachts weithin markt und auch
alles an mir ist macht ja heimatklub
shine control einen bademantel im
hintergrund rumhüpfen sich das ist meine
freundin also beginn der meisterschaft
jetzt mal wie also pump spender hat eine
ganz klassisch dass solche produkte im
kopf den armen bisschen nehme ich mir so
viel hat sich auch komplett verwendet
heißt das alles gleich aussieht
und jetzt leute mit richtig dickem roten
punkt ist ein ganz anderer ton als bei
der haushalt oder ok also das jetzt
nicht stehen haben müssen jetzt mal
klarkommen des alten head of make up
kann ich jetzt mal gut verblenden aber
jetzt schon macht mir eigentlich den
neckar war bisher nur das gesicht leute
[Musik]
haben noch nicht so schön aus aber nur
von mir sieht einfach wieder schnappen
jetzt noch diesen youtube länder dieses
und verteilt das noch ein bisschen
besser damit aber ich finde ich meine
haut ist so viel heller jetzt wird
gleichmäßig sie aus wie irgendeiner von
twilight so von diesen platten menschen
aber als die welt wir machen weiter als
nächstes habe ich hier den concealer von
manhattan und ich guck mal was sie
wieder und macht euch keine ahnung habt
meine augen praktisch auf meine augen
länger auf und verteile ihnen gar nicht
indem ich ihnen mit dem finger ein
klopper ein lokführer alter video und
im körper wird auch ein
[Musik]
fast richtig vielleicht schreibe ich nur
gerade welche gruppe von leuten sich das
anschaut bei guckt mich nicht die leute
an die wollen natürlich über baby lucy
macht gucken sich nicht die leute die
wissen wollen wie man sich richtig
schminkt wahrscheinlich guckt mich
niemand das video hat er trotzdem guckt
schreibt mal make up in die kommentare
ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie an
karneval früher weidete für ungefähr 1
die wir im moment in meinem leben an dem
ich geschminkt wurde außer ein paar live
events oder sogar vorher in die macht
geht aber es war das selbst
[Musik]
bruder
zumal mein bruder das immer benutzt der
mediennutzer liegt professional
finnischen power
ich benutze nur lose lose powder wofür
ich das mache
noch eben entweder man macht aber genau
das brauche ich auch leute also ich
mache jetzt da muss ich sagen heute
wieder staub das finde ich irgendwie
zurechtkommen
und er ist mein ganzer vorliegt sieht
man das schätze ich den spiegel wie man
ein ganzer politiker folglich den fall
aber ich hab's geschafft glaube ich aber
bevor der nächste youtuber irgendwann
man sagt in seinem video geschminkten
sich alle nur macht meine absicht kann
nur leicht sich zu schminken aber bisher
die fäden zieht einfach nur absolut und
natürlich und komisch aus preußen
zufrieden das waren wenig zusammen
ihr browser controlling
beim anfahren bröckling bruder und meine
wangenknochen auch damit mein gewicht
gratuliert wird
und hierbei sehr oft hatten doch sehr
sehr gut verplant
[Musik]
die andere seite dran
für die finde es schön wenn das video
sieht schreiten konnte meinen augen
braunen vierten umrandet erstmal die
form der augenbrauen und danach fahre
ich mit dem stift aus mache ich auch
weiter führten problem übrig habt ihr
schon so rieben augenbrauen umschreibt
ihr gerade vertraglich vor recht gut
[Musik]
wenn man jetzt schon anders augen make
up und im alltag einfach ganz nah am
sintan an dass eine linie bis nach
hinten
okay für schwierig dafür wie es gemacht
wird das richtig habe das war's leute
das wasserspritzen mithin backup bürger
dass ich höre immer wie schwierig es ist
zum lieb schritt machen es stimmt dass
es schwierig ist sagte gut angefangen wo
man hörte meinen kleinen schwester als
sich mehrfach mit mit make-up
experimentiert hat wichtig ist das ist
immer genau identisch aussieht und das
tut es bei mir also habe ich eigentlich
alles richtig gemacht so weit ich meine
wimpern alkohol um wörter und hier
fanden anders denn man kann den leichten
gegenbewegung nach oben das werk noch
mal das volumen und am ende gehe ich
noch mal über nicht setzen damit leider
die vernetzungen bekommen
leute meine kamera zitieren moment mehr
versicherte gucken
[Musik]
das ist meine endprodukt schreibt mir
die kommentare besser auf die sich oder
wien
ich frage mich wirklich die mühe gemacht
habe ist rennen aber ich habe
festgestellt dass ist wirklich schwierig
ist sich zu schminken also ich hab
einfach mit dem volk da habe ich auch
mein bestes also ich hab mir auch mühe
gegeben aber sind einfach gnadenlos
gescheitert also diese augen sind
schrecklich schreibt mir die kommentare
wie ich erfahren habe war das cool waren
wollte mich jetzt hier abonnieren was
mit witten und der platz vom heutigen
video